let's do this neighbor gotcha on on and
by the way bergatsi if you're wondering
is from i think northern india isn't
that where
yeah oh wow oh wow i didn't know that
you're indian yeah yeah 100
what 100 percent how to get a lobby
accent out ironed it out
right and got that southern brawl yeah i
got this other drawer
to get yeah yeah i did it that's right
that's right which runs with the chapati
so you know that makes sense yeah
so congratulations thank you very much
you fellas ever run to each other
because you're in
nashville all the time you ever run into
he did the last big and hungry live
podcast
had a little problem with the sound oh
the mic wasn't working the mic though
what happened was they the guys who shot
it were like but we thought
that you guys were going to record it on
the soundboard which makes sense and
they zany's didn't so but we got one
tomorrow a live one so come on by
uh
i did it you had your shot
nate's the guy though we were saying
after the after we did the live podcast
where
you have this one quality where we're
all pulling bonnie's out of hats and i'm
[ __ ]
look at this and then nate would just
say something really understated and
everybody would [ __ ] laugh their ass
off oh my god well
i feel like you're the last you and
sigur on netflix like
were the last ones that really like blew
up off netflix
yeah the uh yeah i don't know i mean
they almost started like
i don't know who else they're sort of
like putting out i got in there with
netflix very
with the stand-ups like a half hour and
because that was because i did an hour
on comedy central
and then they talked about doing a half
hour stand up said i almost didn't want
to do it because it was like
i was like it's going backwards yep you
know but then at the
you know you realize like i do
understand how big netflix was
and it was like you just want to get in
the long play yeah you're like just do
whatever
but you you got into it before you know
they signed whatever 300
specials yeah you know yeah it's like
they just greenlit like i think 600
specials yeah yeah it's a lot
didn't you say after this this last one
you did where everybody was wearing
masks
so you couldn't tell if you were killing
and then and then he
did what was it when you came back after
the first one they were like we
definitely didn't
oh i did uh so you know like i was
timing my set out
and it was like running like 64 minutes
or something and so they
taped a special after the first show
because we had to do it at universal
studios
uh people they ought to wear they all
got co-with tested and they're negative
and then they start to wear a mask
that's right and then uh so
i can't i didn't realize like i can't
hear them and i was doing drive-in shows
driving theater shows so i was kind of
used to not being able to hear people
but like not seeing their faces
like that and so you just see eyes and
you're like dude these people are not on
board
[Laughter]
it was uh so weird it's so weird
like okay kind of bombing up here
i did 43 minutes yeah that's how my time
i fired through it and they when we got
done you know usually you take
especially you do two and they're like
hey we got that we gotta
have fun on the second one and this one
they were like yo dude we do not have
that this second show is one of the more
important shows of your life
you have to get this to an hour and so
then i
then i had to like kind of slow it down
and i feel like my timing is a little
off in this special like i can
i can tell it like uh it was very
definitely a very different
special all right well that's good to
hear yeah if you haven't watched it yet
you're like yeah
i know right now
how did you like the drive-in shows did
you uh they were great about it
you know i convinced you to do them did
chrysler convince you to do them because
it was like
calling everybody telling me drive-ins
are the best man they honk their horns
like
i don't know dude i talked to i talked
to him about him uh
i wanted to do them because i tend to
like you know it's like going up you
know for you're in a room in a room is
bad
and everybody's bombing and you're like
well let me go you want to feel it
like you and as if it's real bad you're
like i want to i mean i'll bomb with
everybody like
you it's like that kind of thing where i
wanted to be like we're going through
this thing
hopefully it's once it will never happen
again uh so i want to go
i'll go hit all the sights let me go see
what these driving shows are about are
they fun are they not fun
and then go try it and then the reward
of just the audience there dude they
were so
appreciative to even have something to
do especially when you guys were doing
it
oh yeah there was uh and that you know
the timing of the guy we had to do in
chicago
it was raining it's like 45 degrees 500
cars when you walk out honk their horns
flashing their lights and they would
they would honk their horns for laughs
and it kind of worked like it really
they were never
now you know obviously someone's like
just laid on it it wouldn't work
but they were doing it where you
realized like oh we just kind of need a
rhythm
like something yeah and so it's like
they would just be like baby
and once you accept i don't do it my
whole career but like yeah
in the moment when you're seeing 500
cars flash your light tag oh yeah it's
pretty wild it's pretty cool yeah it is
weird going back to how you ran through
your set because you couldn't see their
face and stuff like that i forget where
i was at
wasn't going well and i didn't realize
how fast i was going through my set and
i could have stayed in there's like
dude i look at my brother because my
manager i go how was it was that an hour
and the magic goes dude
that was 26 minutes what
he's like 26 minutes i was like holy
[ __ ] that's like four years ago
yeah i think i'm so sorry man i'm so
sorry it wasn't
going i was in virginia and they had
glass panels
between like everybody oh so they had in
san marcos couldn't hear them [ __ ]
laugh i'm like
they did it and i was just like thank
god this little panel of glass
is going to stop cove it from you know
that yeah it's just optics that's that
[ __ ] well
let's put glass here so that the germs
don't [ __ ] off man
it threw everything off yeah remember
that was like san marcos oh yeah san
marcos i came out i went oh
these these are cool because the because
the virus can't
do this it only goes like this so you
guys are good
oh damn glass oh no
i can't stand it no it doesn't and then
some places are loosely goosey like
cal and i were like some of the first
comics to torture oh yeah oh i've read
about it
[Laughter]
who's laughing now all these [ __ ] are
touring
how can you do this that i look at their
dates i'll be in philly
meanwhile that's called my phone your
doctor's going i don't know i might be
dying
he goes can you count to 25 on one
breath i was like
one two three he goes yeah he goes
you're fine because like
my costume you just you were just
freaking out yeah it was getting bad
you got you got hit pretty hard yeah and
you're like maybe
y'all's name is the one who would die
because i'm a dick i'm like i
don't know you're older yeah but you're
in good shape when they had the list of
people that got covered y'all's name is
like way farther ahead than most
comedians
like you're like it's like tom hanks and
it's pretty quick to y'all
when tom guy everyone's like i hope
tom's okay we get through all the
[ __ ]
time even my friend joey diaz was like
you cocked sucker like
what's going on i thought we were
friends oh man people went off
but then a month later like oh man it's
not that bad and i see all these [ __ ]
on the road
yeah yeah cause yeah yeah you started
touring like
i never stopped yeah yeah yeah i didn't
take a month off maybe i had one date
but i never took a month off no it was
just because of the coach
like two weeks yeah two weeks yeah yeah
but then even like it went to san
antonio went to san antonio i'm like
i look at the man's like dude this is
half capacity goes no we just tell you
la [ __ ] is this to get you out here
like 400 pounds
no doubt correct me if i'm wrong on the
way to the to the final show
i got an amber alert on my phone saying
this is a hot this is a covet hot spot
the county we're in right now is
equivalent hot spot 400 people
well here we go yeah through san antonio
one time when i
uh last last time i was there we were
staying downtown and we go eat
at this like diner it's pretty like it's
like like 11 o'clock
and we're walking back and this guy is
these teenagers
like i see like kind of walking where
you know now i'm you know when
i'm 42 so like i'm you get i'm scared of
teenagers
and so you're like you're like i see him
you're like i'm not i gotta cross the
street
i want to fight these kids like you know
and then one kid just turns and he pulls
out a gun
and starts shooting it like we're we're
we're
here so we're south and he starts
shooting it north and we're
caddy corner to him and like and then we
just take off running
and i got my one opener that's like 50.
i mean he's
i assume just dead like i mean
we're good we're like running and i mean
he said like he can't go anywhere
he's trying to talk his way out he's
over there with him
can i shoot it yeah i'll try to be their
friend that's how i get out of this
shot it like down a street i mean dude
downtown san antonio
and uh what the [ __ ] and then like no
one
it wasn't like anybody cared
like it was oh they were like immune to
it yeah i don't know like so then this
cop
came over and we're like yeah these kids
just shot a gun like i mean if they if
they if he turns the other way he just
shoots at us
yeah and then we go did someone shot a
gun and then they're like
you know what it is what you don't know
welcome to texas
yeah it's like yeah dude yeah who cares
and i looked like on twitter i was like
you know you were like looking like
isn't it going shots going on something
no i mean
nothing dude that's like nothing
teenagers like they're
prefrontal cortex their decision-making
part of their brain is not fully
developed that's a that's a
physiological fact they're going to do
crazy dumb [ __ ]
but like when i was a teenager i was
never like calling here give me this gun
let me shoot this down no they do there
was a guy who said if you were to if you
were to take
most societies traditionally took like
when you were 14
to like 20. they always say like
like put them in the military put them
in school and military because
if you keep them off the street between
14 20 if you look at the
massive the vast majority of violent
crime
it's boys men between the ages of 14
and 20 or 21 or something that's when
you do all the crazy [ __ ] yeah because
your brain's not fully developed you're
like [ __ ] these guys
you know what goose goose and you see it
all the time so the idea was like if you
want to really
really rid the the whole world of
violent crime take anybody from fourteen
twenty boy from fourteen military sports
put them
is a
tough drill to pass here they did a lot
of money
that was what the draft was about
remember when you were drafted you went
to fight
you didn't have a choice well certainly
like uh korea does that right south
korea you got to enlist in the military
you have to do two years
two years or four years israel does
there's a lot of places
yeah russia too yeah you know in
quarantine a lot of people made some bad
choices with money think about the last
last purchase you made in quarantine
that's right think about it man
then there's one of your biggest
purchases of the year insurance can all
relate to that
americans overspend on car and home
insurance by billions
every year that's where the zebra can
help you the zebra's nation's leading
insurance comparison site
for car and home insurance in minutes
you can compare policies from every
major provider for
free all in one independent marketplace
after a few quick questions the zebra
pairs people with the right insurance
company for
them helping everyone save time and
money
there's no hidden fees or fine print
about your personal information
best of all the zebra has no stake in
the policy you choose they don't care
it's trying to help you save money man
they're just there to find you the right
coverage make insurance
your smartest purchase yet all you gotta
do is go to
the zebra.com fighter that's the
zebra.com
fighter with today's low interest rate
it's a great time to refinance your
student loans man who's sick of those
student loans
who's sick of it earnest offers low rate
student loan refinancing
you can check your rate risk free in
just two freaking
minutes with earnest you get flexible
payments you can pick your loan term
all right by refinancing you can reduce
your loan term save money combine
multiple loans and one simple
monthly payment if you have any
questions you can talk to a real human
at earnest for help all right isn't it
time you stop feeling overwhelmed by
student debt
earnest is offering you guys a hundred
dollar cash bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com fighter
terms and conditions apply once again
you get a hundred dollar
cash bonus when you visit earnest.com
fighter to refinance your student loan
no uh available in all states terms
conditions y visit earnest.com for more
details terms and conditions apply
earnest student loan refinance made by
earnest
operations llc nmls number one two zero
four nine one seven california finance
and law license number
eight three three 6054-788-3036 street
suite 401 north san francisco california
94107 visit earnest.com licenses for a
full list of licenses
again that is earnest.com fighter
i always kind of like to be honest i
don't know why i always kind of like
that
i don't know i i like the idea that
you're like it's like you feel this
change
i bet you have more appreciation for
your country yeah you know everybody's
going to do it
and it's it's what you do yeah there's
something about it that also you travel
also you have to go to another country
and see how other people live plus you
got to learn to work
you got to learn to work as a team and
just like your life depends on it you
get in shape
there are a lot of people that believe
in the draft i mean i'm on the fence
about it i don't think it's a terrible
idea you can't do it
you couldn't do it now there's no way
you could do it vietnam changed all that
vietnam was like that was the last of
the draft i believe so
well yeah my dad just they stopped my
dad's 65
and so he was they stopped it i think
the year before he was able to
that he would have been 18. oh god and
they stopped the draft
though those unless those enlisted in
the in the military is
interesting though because there's a guy
there's a ufc fighter
named korean zombie he was in like in
the midst of his career i was like sorry
guys i'm gonna leave for four years and
go do this and i'll come back
before he's back he's back yeah he's
awesome right yeah he's great yeah
remember
i mean uh he's just older so it's like
think about the older four years
ted williams uh for the uh red sox that
sucks yeah
i mean he went to war this dude it's so
crazy
like that stuff should be accounted for
as far as like records go
and they should be like and just a heads
up on these records he went to
war and came back and bought it and then
came back and still like
they would pull them out of their i mean
it would be steph curry
wins mvp and then he goes to war for two
years he's like in the middle east yeah
in the middle east
then he comes back and he's like guys a
little bigger yeah
he refused to go to be drafted and they
took
six years six in his prime mind
yeah six pretty much the amount of money
he would make those six years and he
could have easily gone
and for two years and come back or even
a year because they would have worked
out a deal but he was
too extensive he was like no i'm not
doing it so they he said no vietcong has
ever called me the n-word yeah what a
price to pay like that's why he goes
on the greatest like i mean oh that's
yeah he actually gave something up
[ __ ] yeah gave up i mean six years yeah
six years
and he didn't know if he was going to be
able to come back that's like one of
those things where it's like in the
prime
prime of my life i'm going to stand for
this it's different time now like
no no guy nfl nba big time box in
ufc would be like i'm going to go leave
making all this money and do four years
in the military
pat tillman did it he was one of those
he was one of the ones that
pat took a little different of an animal
right so september 11th happened
he was you know all pro safety for the
cardinals was like oh i'm going to be a
special forces i'm be a ranger and like
okay
and then what's a bummer about his he
died from friendly fire yeah but there's
whole conspiracy with that
yeah that's a bummer yeah there's a
conspiracy behind that yeah
like like the guys were like jealous of
them because you know he had he just
went from the nfl and jumped right into
the special forces
and you know dies my friend yeah who
knows
isn't there a ufc fighter that either
went to war
kennedy oh but no not besides him there
was another guy i thought like uh
that just korean zombie had to do like
you just said
two or three two two yeah yeah you think
are you thinking of a white guy
yeah an american tim kennedy was an
operator besides tim though there was
it was uh another guy other than tim
that i thought i saw that
was in the army that is a ufc fighter
now
well he was in the army and brian stan
brian stan was in the army well he
retired about nine years ago
um
[Music]
was in the army he was a medic in the
army it could be near
but i thought he was a white i thought
it was a white guy i was singing i love
if we're not nailing this guy
that's all
i right it was a white guy i could be
wrong i
i don't know he's like no he was white i
liked him
[Laughter]
i see where you're getting that
christian
people want brian stan to be the uh
yeah randy couture was in brian stan
neil magne
look at tim's the face of so these are
all the us these guys this is a tour
it could be randy couture yeah oh you're
going old school i think you're talking
about current flowers
no no no jesus christ dude yeah i'll
give you yeah randy couture
for sure awesome um tim is
tim tim was literally doing i think
secret mission he still is wow
crush dude i i go hey dude you want to
go on food truck because he's
flew in he's on my show food diaries
tomorrow
he [ __ ] goes yeah i'm in send me a
picture helicopter
full camo i'm like where are you going
he's like talk to you later
like jesus christ and i called him and
this is how he answered the phone i
called him up and i just get this i go i
can't follow him i just hear this
he just goes america yeah he's the best
hogs or something uh
terrorist yeah no is he invited he
invited brennan
you know he said to us he's not my thing
do you guys want to get on horseback and
kill hogs with a spear tomorrow no
but then he goes i'll rent us a
helicopter shoot him out of the
helicopter like yeah i know they do that
that's not my fault
yeah it's not what i did but yeah you
would do it yeah 100
there's no way
you know he has to be an endangered
animal yeah people hate hunger but
they couldn't know they could shoot the
hogs out there it's right up there
because they're past they
tim were talking to killing them for
sure he's like do you know what they do
brendan like i have no clue dude
i love first of all i love pork second
of all i would shoot the [ __ ] out of all
the hogs have you hunted anything
yes are you a hunter nate i'm not really
yeah
you know maybe it's your boy yeah that's
the accent southern drama you know i
just assume you hunt
no yeah no we we didn't grow up with
any of that stuff like i had buddies
they did i had buddies that would
you know if a deer got hit by a car
they'd pull over and it was
recent enough fresh yeah fresh enough
they just put them back a truck
and you grew up in uh old hickory yeah
it's like a suburb of nashville
and you love about them yeah i love it
i'm back then we've
been back uh five six years something
like that uh it's the best
nashville's i'm a big big obviously a
nashville fan nashville has
changed so much from when i was there
when i was a kid
blowing up everybody's moving there
everybody's moving there it's uh
downtown has gotten pretty crazy i mean
we never went downtown a ton but uh
it's gotten just so it's a whole nother
vibe kind of down there and
what's interesting about your stories
you're like you came up with all the new
york guys
yeah so i always consider myself a new
york guy like i was in uh i moved to
chicago first
for two years with like pete holmes
there hannibal
like that kind of crew and then we all
went to new york after that
and i was in new york for about eight
and a half years and that's where i
really i was at boston comedy club all
the pete's show
crashing i did exactly that oh and so i
love that show i barked
and did all that would see chappelle
come in like you know back when chapelle
was doing chappelle show
uh and uh and then so like and when he
kind of
spelled then and that all got weird and
he left
uh and then burr patrice like i would
see yeah
that's my favorite i was just sitting in
patrice's car
uh so he wouldn't get a ticket because
right outside boston comedy club you
couldn't park
and so he made you sit in the front yeah
so i'd go sit in it if a cop came out
just driving around
i timed it i've told some of these
stories about time this set once
uh when him and burr were doing the hbo
one night stand taping and i went to the
taping
so when they were running it this is
like i don't understand like
tv so i'm thinking like they have to be
at 30 minutes like i don't
understand that you could do more or
less whatever yeah
and so like patrice goes up and like
runs his set one night at boston
and i was like i walked over i was like
that was uh 35 minutes and he's like
okay and then walked away from me like i
mean did not ask me to do that
nor won it but i thought like i'm doing
that i'm like doing the right thing
i'd like to sit there at the stop watch
like go tell him like a
lunatic
but he was uh yeah but so i i've always
like i'm around those
new york guys was where i was
interesting to me because burr
you know you know this brian you've been
around it longer than anybody here is
where
burr's like all you guys knew how
special burr was but he didn't catch on
to like much
later it wasn't until it's almost like
louis c.k like louie was
in the comedy world was big and you guys
knew he was a savage but he didn't like
blow up to really late that one night
stand from
burr i think so i was there and so it
was this
yeah 2004 five
six maybe somewhere on a thing the
opening thing happened right after that
yeah and so uh that was when we started
hearing bill yeah
it was like it was like all that stuff
and that's uh most people's careers it's
like
a lot of stuff kind of happens yep and
then it's like
you know but no one realizes that bird's
been doing comedy for 12 years or
something at that point 10 years
and then uh he would but when i remember
his one night same time this is when he
did the joke about going to harlem
and it's hard for him to breathe you
know the higher you go you're like yeah
it's kind of they're kind of crazy
yeah and uh i remember
the crowd like they were they didn't
unders
like he murdered so hard that you could
feel the audience just kind of be like
i don't even know what this is like this
is crazy dude
like who is you know that just who is
that guy like
that was nuts dude and he came out and
because i remember we go watch them at
caroline's and i mean there's you know
they have the curtain pulled
caroline's curtain caroline will have a
curtain to close half the room off
and so like i remember you going in
there at the curtains pool and then it
was like next year like the
general manager is like you can't come
in and we're like just let us watch and
they're like no we're too sold out
it was two sold out and then it just was
like what happened with social media too
because when
you would do stand-up and you crushed a
room whatever would
if that would just go away you didn't
have people online talking about you you
didn't have all these people
sharing these clips and ideas so what
happens is when you start sharing that
stuff it just catches on
and everybody's talking about you
podcasting and social media
that's what created change the game yeah
that's why you were able to make crazy
money but i always say this like guys
like burr and
even rogue and everybody nobody was
making close to the money they're making
now nobody
nobody nobody was making burr's kind of
like the quiet
businessman too because his you know his
network all things comedy
yeah is people don't realize how big
that thing is yeah like that's his
[ __ ] you money yeah that thing's big boy
yeah my podcast is on it oh is it really
i don't know podcast yeah what's it
called the nate land podcast
okay i'm not trying to do you know too
much with it
you don't like doing it no no i do it's
actually why have you been doing it
though
uh no it'll be a year in june so
you started i just started yeah yeah
yeah it's like a coveted baby
like you're like yeah this thing's still
around uh they uh
it was but what i have liked is hey i do
it in my house uh
it's very easy and i do like being funny
because i'd realize like when you're
the greatest thing about being in new
york and even out here when you're
around a bunch of comics you have to be
funny to each other a lot
and if you're not that it's not good for
you as a comedian like that's what makes
you
be better is to be funny it's a yes
and so like starting to do that like i
can tell how much it's helped
with my like building this new hour just
with my stand up
like you're just thinking about angles
more because like when you don't you're
just watching tv
that's what comedy is is think about
angles like you think of something
that's funny and then you got to think
of like what's
how am i going to make this funny and so
if you're not being funny
regularly that got that you lose that
quick so like with your
with the new hour now because you shot
your special so are you
your home club zanies yeah and are you
getting up there like all the time like
because there's guys like segura even
bert
where they're they're you know joe coy
where they're put they're
making their hour on the road they're
developing as they start doing
the road yeah like they're not building
it at the economy store the improv or
bit by bit they're literally doing it on
the road i would do it
now i do it like that i'd do it uh i i
would build on the road normally now
there's
a different scenario with covet so when
i taped this one
i did some more stuff with zane's with
zayn's we always have like a new
material night and an all-star show that
is not announced so it's nice that we
can show up we cannot show up is that
monday night
yeah monday nights and tuesdays usually
is when we do them and then
uh so i was able to go there and do it
and and then
start building stuff and start thinking
of new jokes and stuff and then now i'm
i'm doing clubs
comedy clubs now so i went on a pretty
i'm on a good run of these comedy clubs
uh and so like doing those six shows and
like you build you write more i
i remember hannibal said it to me a long
time ago and and it's
rung true is uh you right on the road i
was like do you write more on the road
because i'm
you know i was coming from a spot world
where you're like you got to do spots
and he's like i write more than i've
ever written and he realized you do
because you know like after you go
headline and you're doing hours all
weekend and then you go to a spot it's
weird
like it's hard for you to get back into
if you've got to be tighter you've got
to be
aware it's such a yeah and it's all it's
different it's just different
it's not a and it's a good thing but i
think you're supposed to
that's the way you're supposed to go
then you get out of the clubs and then
the new guys come up in the clubs like
that's
sometimes people get too stuck in these
comedy clubs where you're like dude if
you're selling out
not that you don't go to these comedy
clubs you don't be doing 500 spots a
week you're doing
six hours on the weekend that's where
you need to go build and then you got to
let the new comics yes
come in and get out of their way now did
you keep the same energy when you did
rogan did you tell rogan this
although rogan
kind of with the store was like a big
deal of that coming back
like i feel like that was a him being
around i'm not against
these comics doing that stuff i'm just
but sometimes you do have to be aware
of like you got to get room for these
young comics like
it's so i came up when i went to the
seller when i was trying to get in the
comment seller in new york
it was very hard they cuz it was you
know before that was like this like ray
romano goes and gets a tv show or
seinfeld like
these guys kind of move and then the new
guys come in
and then there was a point where it was
like it was kind of all these comics
that are not going on the road they're
just making money in new york and
they're staying there doing spots
well we don't get i don't i don't i
don't get spots none of no one but
you know below you get spot it's like
just a couple people it doesn't
it's supposed to be because that you can
make actually that's the best pretty
good money and some people were doing
five six spots
a night in new york for sure so they'd
hit every club did you ever do that were
you going oh yeah seven i did seven
yeah the most i did seven seven in one
night and now you get good that way
because you're literally your whole
night is going
you're getting paid for every spot so
you can stay in new york and pay your
rent
and in new york you don't need a big
place and it's so a lot of people
who are killers but that's why in new
york you see [ __ ]
i'm not gonna mention names who have the
craziest 20 minutes
i'm talking about 20 minutes that just
literally shakes it shakes the [ __ ]
room
past that though because they got so
comfortable with that 21 gets there's
always new tourists coming in 21 21 gets
tough
and that's why they don't have a special
that's why you see [ __ ] who are
kind of monsters but they're just
staying there and they stay there
because they're making a lot all that
money so what happens
is you make crazy you're making really
good money you live in the best city in
the world you get an apartment
smoking weed and you just sound badly it
depends where you're
when did you know you had to get out of
new york so i left
uh well dude speaking on that like with
comics dude think that so when i first
started headlining and go on the road
it was like i did uh you know you got to
do an hours at chicago zaney's
and which was the first club i ever went
up at and uh so
i was doing this show there and i
remember i had to do 45 minutes and dude
i was like tired at 35 i was tired the
audience was tired
because i was coming from a spot world
yep where you're like
just like on top of it then you're like
oh i gotta learn how to the pacing
yeah like pace it like you still want to
murder the whole time but you wanna it's
just different
different jokes are longer and stuff
like that but so when i moved i moved
out uh i was in new york i i kind of
when i first went there i knew i wanted
to
i want to get past at every club and so
like i was like the goal was to like
do that and be passed everywhere so i
can you know dangerfields are
i think was the last one but it was like
to get past
that big reason i moved was i read uh
uh jerry wintrough he was like a
producer for ocean's 11
a big hollywood guy i read his book and
when he was in he was in new york as an
agent
and he said he knew anytime he started
feeling comfortable it was time to make
a change
and so when i read honestly when i read
that quote that made
so much sense that hit me so like it was
like i was
i was getting i wasn't grinding to find
these spots anymore i was in these clubs
you're doing these spots
yeah and i was like i'm very comfortable
and uh
and i knew so i knew i was like all
right i didn't change it up and that's
when i moved out here
to be like you know to come out here now
you're amongst different comics that
you're not around as much
foreign territory yeah and you've got a
was your daughter born at that time
she was born she's eight and so she was
born uh
she would have lived i mean i had an old
joke about it where i said jesus
we had her born in tennessee uh i didn't
want her to be born in new york because
i didn't want her to grow up thinking
she's better than me
[Laughter]
so she is
but we were we were in new york
and uh so she was only there for a
couple months and then we
we left the day i drove across the
country i drove across the country and
uh my wife and our new two
three-month-old daughter they were gonna
fly back home to nashville
basically to let me get to l.a and then
fly by here
and so this is when hurricane sandy hit
and so i
we had to leave i had to go just get in
the car and go and so my
wife's dad came up to help her and he's
older i mean he's like was in his late
70s
and uh he comes and then they get stuck
in new york because of the hurricane
which was like on the news was like
basically just like
protect old people and babies and i left
my wife in both of those
right
hot chicken sorry guys you'll be fine
you gotta make it in hollywood baby
that's like i have a recurring dream
about that where my my family
my kids are stuck somewhere and i can't
get to them yeah i have a weird dream
there's like there's a cage and i'm like
i gotta get to them they're like sir you
gotta wait in line i gotta get to them
i can see that my kind of reason for you
dude i read too many serial killer books
and watch too many like
documentaries on it because i hear any
sound in my house and i'm up all night
oh yeah bro so the [ __ ] am i i read that
urban
stalker book and then i heard like a
creak and i got my [ __ ] ar-15 out
i'm in my under the arrow 15 is going to
be very loud and blow everybody serious
drums out i'm going to need you
to get yourself a shotgun have that too
or just a handgun have that
shot going pretty loud though shotgun's
very
it's very loud yeah but also bird shot
doesn't go into the other room problem
with an ar-15
it goes it can go if you miss what
you're going to do or whatever it's
going to go through five walls and
the other house remember that you can't
use birdshot though why
it's elite it's considered inhumane
listen to me
right now i worked out before before
i know that education let me educate you
i worked at a gun store for
eight months like i'm like familiar with
this type of stuff yeah
you are right best thing to do is
usually use a shotgun because
my girl has a shotgun out of the rfid
and you've got to cut listen to me i'm
using a shotgun
yeah if you come into my house i'm going
to shoot you with a shotgun and if
somebody's in your house though in
california and you
use birdshot you're fine you're fine i'm
not going to get pers prosecuted because
it did they're not going to say it's
inhumane to use birdshot versus
a nine millimeter hollow point slug now
i'm using the reason i want birdshot is
not going to go in the other room and
hit one of my kids when they wake up
i want i want that bird shot scatter gun
that's what bug chat does too though
that's what i mean yeah
buck shots that's that's double out
right that's like double odd like is the
the home defense type that happens i
used up a lot when i got a group
when i got a cartel bunch of guys in a
car coming in
so you might have to use those against
the homeless because you live in venice
this is true too
i got well so okay so i got daddy's
daddy that is a problem on his head
probably can't sell his house oh yeah
bro the whole the hole is coming
to your house oh they're all over well
they sleep they start fire i got them in
my front
they got them right i got them right in
the yard they're squatting you can't
sell the house
my girlfriend my girl can smell and i'm
not kidding
smell the guy over here so i got i got
some plans
i need to toughen her up yeah yeah and
you got salsa you got all kinds of stuff
yeah i got to give her like dollars and
stuff to hand out when she walks out
just keep her prepared you got to pay
high taxes and get nothing for it it's
going to be great yeah
great yeah yeah double out is for uh if
i want to kill a bunch of people in a
car with one shot
i got four perpetrators in a car they
roll up before they get out of the car
that is definitely a slug yeah
slug is gonna kill one guy i want double
lock because it goes it's it's a it's a
shotgun shell
with with essentially nine millimeter
slugs yes
and they just go have you seen the whole
slugs make though
slugs will put a hole through not only
you but the person that's
correct that's correct that's why that's
what we're looking for
i got four guys looking for damage i
have four guys in a car i want to hit
all four
so what i want to do is from a distance
uh let's call it 50 yards i've thought
about this
and everybody's like ah and now i'm like
see don't come to my don't roll up my
house with all your [ __ ] guns in your
car bro hey do you own a gun before you
got out
uh yeah i don't think you do dude don't
feel like you have to say yes because
you're around us
i'm not behind it you know what don't
act tougher because you're not
miss me right now he goes you'll find
out guys
can't do nothing i think we'll [ __ ]
that's cool i love
god if i work out dude
no i'm trying to say if i wanted to say
if i have a gun yeah i feel you
uh but i guess yeah i do i went and
looked at property in nashville
without an exaggeration i'm not kidding
every house i looked at
that was that had been inhabited there
was a gun
safe in every house yeah one guy went to
his house and he had
america vest and everything like a whole
thing right there
yeah they love their concept yeah
they're carrying two
is it right is it right to carry yeah
yeah as i have a
i have a license i have all that what
are like guys i'm rambo basically
i know right guys i've killed someone
yeah
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah that's how it is in
arizona i'm from arizona it's a right to
carry i'm gonna kill you but you're not
a you're not a big gun guy either
yeah um i don't know
uh i don't have a lot of knowledge in
guns it's not that i don't like them
like
when we went and shot with uh coleon in
uh dallas or whatever
that was fun you know i i actually
really liked that i'm like everybody
should kind of take a
course like this just to understand guns
better because i i
was very safe i felt good about it i
didn't feel weird about it if you're
around someone knows what they're doing
it's like yeah if you were on someone
that knows what they're doing colin
knows his [ __ ] yeah peter's going to set
us up in houston
shoot more stuff yeah i'm just saying
i just don't know knowledge that's my
thing with shooting they give me the gun
the target's out two two
oh that's cool and then i want to leave
it's like oh no we're going to spend the
whole day here we have all these guns
i'm like then they'll just
shoot the bullets like all right how
long are we
about three four hours you know hours
two hours
like if you really want to learn like
like defensive stuff they teach you so
differently like
one of the things that people know is
like when you are in a gun fight what
you'll see is people like
what so you know you're taught to shoot
like this apparently with a gunfight
like people will pull their gun out and
they
they're they reach behind them instincts
really because you don't know what's
behind you so you'll see a lot of people
go like this
i would never do that you don't know
though no i do i've shot a gun
not one time because you're
not gonna want to fall
distinctive to get away from you yeah so
what people do is they go
so they always practice like lean
forward boom actually what's going to
happen is if the dudes are coming out
you're shooting
you and you're going to run about and
when you as you're moving back a lot of
times you're without realizing you're
feeling for what's behind you like a car
you don't want to run into oh god
they'll study how people actually behave
right so the people who pull their gun
even people are trained and as they're
moving back they're getting behind a car
and they're they're reaching back like
this here's the other thing when people
get stabbed
almost always i think it's something
like 90 percent of people are
right-handed
so almost always if you see people
stabbing somebody they stab they come
down and they're stabbing with their
right hand
low it's very rare that they do this for
whatever reason most of the time the
truth
i think it's probably easier yeah so
they're getting more you get more torque
yeah yeah you can get it watch this
so they they'll a lot of guys teach you
as you're coming grab the hand like
terrible idea you're getting cut yeah
yeah
because i'm gonna do this you're gonna
pull away and i'm getting cut right man
what they say is either run or you try
to you try to move the hand because you
know it's coming this way and then
hit or whatever it is so they did oh
when you actually study
i've also i've also watched too many
gangster movies this kid grown up so
when we shot in
texas i was firing to the side like this
yeah and it's super frowned upon you
know what's [ __ ] about movies
is that there are a lot of us stories
you see this too
where [ __ ] people because they've
watched movies a guy comes at him with a
gun
and they start kicking and trying to
punch the guy with the gun and they get
shot
so they're like oh i know what to do
yeah
can the guy goes
but also what's weird too is that colin
showed this he's like you're on movies
they put silencers on and you're like oh
you can't hear anything he's like
i'm gonna put a silence on you guys tell
me how loud it is you put the silence on
it's
so loud now it's not like two it was
so [ __ ] loud andy stumpf like what's
the point yeah andy stuff on his podcast
cleared hot
he's the seal team six guy he has this
section where i
we call it tactical [ __ ] and he'll
show me
movie scenes and i have to tell him
what's wrong with the scene
so every time how many times you've seen
special forces guys
cover of night come in on their ar-15s
they've got
suppressors
[Music]
guess what do you know how loud do you
know how [ __ ] loud
you put a suppressor on an ar-15 they're
so loud it hurts your ears it's still so
hard
you hear it you're gonna [ __ ] hear it
unless yeah yeah what's up
yeah those stupid like you can they do
have
gum cages where you actually are totally
silent we just hear the
the style of the chamber but for the
most part when you see an
m4 or whatever those things are [ __ ]
you can't silence it yeah
we shot in uh jim let me hear like an m4
with a silencer i want to see how loud
that is sure
we shot guns and uh like i said we never
i never grew up with guns and then uh so
then now we did go we got trained and
did all that because they always say
dude keep your hand in your chest
because people put their hand in front
of the gun
like and they sh you so you're like when
you draw like someone could be like this
and if you just fire real quick so you
keep your hand on your chest
oh let's see this now this so that's it
that's i want to hear this
let's hear this now 22s are pretty quiet
already yeah you put a silence on that
it's not bad it's more than the bad it's
pretty loud though it's loud
but it's not as that does it sounds like
an air like an air
shot or something like you're like but
it's uh it's it's better than
the you know texas planking and it looks
awesome yeah it looks
it does look cool it's real hard to get
guns here isn't it
yeah yeah pretty easy for me to get it
they're a lot it was easier than i
thought
yeah it was way easier like i've never
been a gun guy and then i had some
issues so i'm like oh i need guns and it
was
very easy to get a shotgun ar-15 two
ar-15s and o'clock
you just it's just specific guys
california you can't get a surprise
i don't know you cannot get a suppressor
like that yeah
nashville you can get everything you
want california there's so many
regulations like
a magazine can only be like this big
yeah you can't have a suppressor you
can't even have a flash muzzle
it they do you can't have like a full
clip oh it has to be a short clip we're
in texas
right here no here yeah you it's a
minimum 10 round uh
limit for 10 round magazine out here
right
they have to have safeties on it all the
rules for here is
so dumb yeah there's optics optics
yeah like shorter clips there's not
going to be mass shooters like
or they just reload yeah and you would
know because you worked in the thing
like if the guy's in your house
and he's got stuff in his hands and you
shoot him you go to jail
you can't if somebody's stealing stuff
you can't shoot a guy but if he's
in and also if he's leaving and you
shoot him in the back you're [ __ ]
right
my father-in-law says different because
you've always told me that he's like if
they're in your house then you feel
threat in their house
but if you shoot him in the back he says
you're gonna be fine by state
yeah but you're also gonna be you're
gonna be sued i think what they were
saying is that
you will be in court forever if you
shoot somebody in the back
you're gonna get sued for that and
you're you're probably going to lose
there's a castle doctrine and
tennessee's a great state for guns
that are there uh but they have a castle
doctrine so like
if you have a garage so if someone has
like a third third garage
and they're if the third garage is
attached to the house like you can you
can walk to it without ever going
outside
if someone gets in that garage you could
shoot them if your garage if you have to
go through a door to go outside then
back into another door
they can steal whatever they want in
that garage
it's like it has to be attached they
have to like if someone's like
protesting that was the guy in st louis
like the the guy the kid they no no the
the two the married couple that walked
out with the gun oh yeah like
no matter what you want to be if like
i'm bored with like whatever they did
but i don't i'm pretty sure you can't go
out there and like
thread them and wave the gun like that
no you can't so you're not like if
someone's protesting on your property
you can't just go out there with a gun
they have to
really show intent yeah that they're
coming in the house like they have to
almost
be kicking for you they throw like
something molotov cocktails at your
house
then you could i mean i think that's
intense well but then in the air
those people you talking about those two
uh white couple they came out
like people are protesting outside their
house they walk out
protecting their health yeah get i get
totally the logical they were walking by
and they walked out like i think there's
black lives matter's watching yeah and
they came on their
lawn with their big automatic rifles
yeah
i get the logic though they don't they
knocked the fence down it was a gated
thing
i get there them being nervous and like
trying to be like don't come
try to because i don't know if they were
worried about it not up it's like a
tricky thing where it's like
you know everybody that was the pro guns
want them to be like no leave these
people alone
and there's another side of it that's
like i don't know if you are really
truly allowed to go do
like go just flash your gun to like
scare someone off yeah
i don't would you do it in the car like
if you think someone's about to come
yeah you're could you show them the gun
and then like show it like you can yeah
yeah i would yeah that's your coffin if
you can't
yeah but also those people that did that
it's like by them
doing i get i understand why they did it
but them doing that does that entice
more violence like
because if someone on the other side has
guns you get your guns out is that just
going to entice the gunfight you know
yeah i had to get why they did it i get
why they did it yeah that's why
everybody has a gun
for that because if you're nervous about
that situation did i ever tell you that
where where um
i bought a gun and the guy said he told
me about like there's a there's a manual
that they sell it's about everything you
need to know as a california gun owner
and they have all these different
scenarios and he said that's where i
learned about if he's holding property
and you're in the house don't shoot him
don't shoot him in the back there all
these issues right
and then he said to me he said um i
would say this where he quizzed me
and he goes now now here's a question
for you i get a lot of guys on
if somebody has got a bat and they're
clubbing your dog
in front of you they're killing your dog
can you shoot it because it's a human
you can't because
i go yeah i'll shoot him right in the
[ __ ] head he goes you're going to
jail forever and i go what
because the dog is not it's property
it's not
it's not considered like now if he's
clubbing that dog in
yeah well you know what i'd say is i'd
be like well then he came after me
obviously
yeah he said then like you know the dog
granted just make sure like i've had
cops tell me
drag [ __ ] drag him
inside like dragon shoot him
dane cook did a joke but it was based on
a true story he had a stalker
and the he had a friend who worked for
the lapd and the lapd guy goes okay
here's what i want you to do
you open your front door you have a
shotgun he goes nobody's buy a shotgun
he goes you open your front door and
watch her feet
mousetrap as soon as her feet cross your
threshold your door threshold
like a vampire you shoot her and then
you sh
then shoot into the ceiling and then you
tell the cops i gave a warning shot in
the ceiling
and then i shot her there's a female
stalker she was
crazy she shaved her eyebrows do you
know the story no no
i love dane though the dane did the cop
he told him on stage so i don't think
i'm outside
did the cop tell dan cook and also don't
do this on a special or anything like
that yeah
i don't know because he did it at the
lab you have any issues with dane no no
no i'm uh
i'm a big guy i'm a big fan that guy
blew up uh and that that was a true sign
of people
don't like people that have success yes
because that guy blew up and then the
whole the family guy
makes a joke about him everybody starts
hating on him and you're like that dude
was like
killing it like and y'all loved him he
was kevin hart before kevin hart like he
was so
people don't like people to do good they
don't want people to do that when i was
doing mad tv
their favorite pastime was to make fun
of jim carrey
the great jim carrey summer's almost
here it's a thick boy summer and you
don't want to be that guy with your
shirt tucked in
guts sticking out don't be that guy what
you need to do is listen your thick
friend here get a on tucket
shirt that's right they have performance
shirts that wick the sweat from your
thick ass
they have short sleeve button downs
polos all right they're made for you to
be outside
put some khaki shorts on get some dope
kicks wear a non-tucked
shirt they're perfect for you getting
back to normal life maybe you got a
family reunion maybe going on vacation
with the fan whatever it is
untuck it make sure it's designed to be
worn on tuck
that fits for all shapes and sizes
untuck it offers up to size
x x x l for you thickies out there they
also have slim fitting
relax tall fits we got you covered
untuck it has
85 stores nationwide free returns and
exchanges
all you got to do is use the code
fighter for 20 soft your first purchase
at
ontucket.com untuc
kit.com promo code fighter 20 off on
tuckett.com
people don't like people to do good they
don't want people to do that when i was
doing mad tv their favorite pastime was
to make fun of
jim carrey the great jim carrey what
yeah
that so when i was doing mad tv they're
saying it was like kids and comedy
all the people to make fun of me there
is the benefit of being
ancient well i was doing that i used to
make fun well not to your
you it wasn't your idea but they used to
have brand new skits making fun of jim
carrey well i did a skit which was
which was which was it was kind of like
no it's not
a school of acting so i was like showing
you how to use your apps and all that
but i i always respected the [ __ ] out of
him because well
because well he's genius he's undeniably
amazing yeah but he's also coming
in today everybody who was cool in the
comedy world was like
slow dental surgery or jim carrey
and i was like but but that's with
anything that's a success like
people like you'll hear big names go oh
kevin hart's name funny i'm like oh
oh really he's not well apparently
somebody thinks he's funny because he's
the
they say with larry's successful selling
club guy they're like oh
you should just do that then go do that
and get go do that yeah yeah
yeah yeah if it's that simple go grab
that 15. but it's it's with it's with
anything like you'll get in music like
drake people make fun of
you oh he's so soft like yeah i don't
need my do it i don't need my guy to be
a gangster rapper like he's obviously
the biggest in the world for a reason
well
it's like who else could pull off ace
ventura right that was
who else could i thought that was
[ __ ] genius i was in the i was in the
theater for that
i sat in the theater and watched them
and everybody first of all first of all
when you watch them on
in living color everybody tuned in for
that [ __ ] oh so
everybody everybody tuned in for that
dude doing fire marshall bill and all
that [ __ ]
they were all like where are we playing
the chick in the weight room oh my god
via the pictures
every day
we talk about that [ __ ] we at
work the next day everybody be like did
you see what he did this week
so what got these [ __ ] to the
dance is genius
and when he did uh ace ventura please
find me
please find me a movie or an actor
whoever did something that [ __ ]
insane because
we were dying my mind at an original
school for a while that's a very
original
alex alec baldwin said we i was doing
this huge movie
it was [ __ ] huge and it was going to
be the biggest thing and along comes
this guy nobody's heard of called
jim carrey doing the craziest [ __ ] and
all of america went
thanks alex
yeah i think about it i'm like i don't
know another actor or actress
that could pull that character you think
of me myself and irene oh
gosh when he was the other guy yes
kicks to the nose with his nose no
remember when she thinks he's gonna kill
him yeah yeah he's
shakes everybody's like what's up [ __ ]
fart he's like so intense
she's like i found rope i found a dildo
in the back and
she's like that you're that's for you
yeah it's for you sweetie
he's like all graphics and his sons are
black
yeah and no one wants to tell him yeah
yeah and then he's at the barbecue he
goes god damn how long are you telling
us those kids wieners as big as the
sausages
that's the sausages up he's like do you
not know the
water beads off the [ __ ] back he's
like yeah
so oh god the movie's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah
liar liar yeah i'm a good one too fun
we're taking jane
dude he had such a rough oh yeah the
mask
uh
[Music]
so like it was like i remember being a
young man going
it's like the burning bush i couldn't
look at her face i was like what i was a
kid and i was rock hard in the theater
god damn look at her
smoke you don't get one beautiful show
you don't get more beautiful i didn't
even know she was
looked like that in this oh dude she's
she was
she was well you don't get hot you don't
get more beautiful it just gets
different it doesn't get more beautiful
she married the guy from good charlotte
she did yep uh one of the twins from
good times she was so cool benny or
whatever she's
so gorgeous i think it's benji yeah
she's astonishing like yeah like why
quit acting she retired
good oh really she did it whatever she
did yeah after a while
yeah she did the charlie's angels too
she was part of that franchise
pass on that yeah you didn't like that
movie not up for me but
the women in it though i mean like that
the most lucy lucy lou
little mirrorless come on what happened
to her she i saw her i saw her get her
hollywood
oh hollywood star not too long ago
well i bet he's funny like i hit the
water
brendan what what that's such a [ __ ]
insult but so far what did he say it's
such a great
yeah come on normal dude yeah but he's
in a big
he's a rock he's a rock star he's in a
big yeah
what would you give his la rating
cameron d has his husband
uh cameron diaz is la-10 he's a four
you give him a full i mean he's probably
he's a brayer [ __ ]
talented and cool [ __ ] no that's what
i'm saying i bet he's a great
hey by the way they got money you know
by the way though it's also not easy for
cameron diaz necessarily to find a guy
like that that that
is she in trust yeah he has his own
money like yeah he's got he's probably
he's probably a dude yeah i always heard
that like uh
he looks like a dude someone said like
you get money and stuff like you gotta
uh if you're the people are super famous
they gotta find someone
that has as much as them to lose that
makes sense so you can't like go
to someone you know because that that
doesn't have anything because then they
could just
rip your part of life apart but you have
to if you have someone that like you
that
kind of scenario yeah i don't need your
money you don't need my money
like it's it's almost back to like what
it really is it's like uh
he's also going okay you're in your 40s
almost 50
and i and i want to i want to and i and
i want to go with this and i love the
mask and he's also looks like
i love you i was a big max fan yeah so
here we are
i have money you have money it looks
like
like people hated nickelback and you're
like i mean i am i i love all these
songs like
are they not catchy yeah i'm like we all
know so many records
they're like the butt of every joke but
they're catching up they're everything
because they're so popular wait so you
guys all you guys all like it oh yeah
i'm like i don't get the hate on them
somebody my mic and mike mike's a jiu
jitsu guy i think mike's a black belt
and jiu jitsu and his brothers
they started as brothers and stuff but i
mean they're pretty if you meet him he's
a cool
really good this is how you remind me to
what don't you know him
i thought you knew him from no
absolutely you're looking in the wrong
why not it's just not the kind of rock
that i get down with it just
but you're like hardcore like yeah it's
something to lose [ __ ]
right i don't know what do you like
creed okay
i heard about you dude we've had entire
big and hungry podcasts about how much
he loves oasis and i'm like
you can't call them the greatest band in
the world oh yeah we can
no you can't we we've done two albums
and who cares two albums and who
good spells feelings i don't get i don't
get people who like that guy is there
any band you're into like that like
i don't have any bands sure who do you
listen to
uh i mean nickelback
no i listen to like country i'm uh dana
and shay i listen to there's a this i
love dude my buddy plays with dan and
shane oh yeah he's one of the guitars
for yeah
they're amazing you could be one lead
man if you could be like one
lead singer in one band who would it be
who would like what
i'm being freddie mercury and queen yeah
come on man without
or robert dicks in my mouth or robert
plant well without you oh you said i'll
be freddie murphy without the words
comes to the whole package bro all right
well whatever
if you could be the guy yeah liam
gallagher
yeah dude you can't at the pantheon you
can't say
the lead singer of oasis two albums you
can't
that's all they have is two albums
come on how about bono how about spring
how about david bowie how about [ __ ]
roger waters how about you aerosmith
errol how about [ __ ] stephen tyler i
would like to say
this i can't even have
i can't even have the conversation with
you i would think uh lincoln park what's
his name
not bad minus the suicide but he was
really good
well i mean you said freddie mercury i
mean you you have some stuff going on
i'm like yeah i'm gonna have suicide but
i mean you guys
you got that when no one had it like it
was like a real big problem
uh you know you don't know much about
oasis so that's why i'm not gonna have a
conversation with you
you should go talk to my question my
buddy tried my
my tour manager my buddy that uh i grew
up with and he's
like he's obsessed with oasis yeah like
obsessed that's their family
burns i talked to steve byrne backstage
one time at the store
about oasis have you ever you've never
met i'm in two oasis group texts
one of them was with adam eagles have
they done anything relevant
have they have they done anything no
have they done anything relevant lately
they broke up in 2009 they both do their
own thing yeah and you follow both of
them still yeah
yeah he's kind of one of those kind of
the main guy is kind of
out there right he's got his guys quote
if you look at leonard they're really
funny yeah he's fine they talk a lot of
[ __ ] to each other
yeah that's good because they're they're
brothers the lead guitarist they're
still friends
no they don't talk
they talk [ __ ] to each other all the
time real hard interviews and like it's
just
it's more funny it's like it's just like
brotherly love like i think
i think he came in look at that that's
an amazing i think he came in and said i
need him i need to print that out and
blow that up i already got it i mean i
got you like oh i have that one blown up
you like
cutting the top uh middle one yeah i
have that one blown up and
it's all framed in mine that one in my
house yeah was it blink 182 where they
came in and he goes uh i like you guys
yep you like us and he goes i i've been
listening to your album man you guys are
you guys doing a good job and he goes oh
you like us and he goes didn't say that
no no no this is what it was he saw them
live
on stage he goes that was [ __ ]
amazing and then they go
you like us and he goes didn't say that
i like this guy there's quotes
with blink 182 too yeah and i know
they're like
that's another thing people make fun of
blink 182 but they're [ __ ] huge
i don't hear too many people make fun of
blink 182 i remember blink 182.
i posted a picture with travis because i
went there at his concert you don't like
blink way too
not really you're too young yeah you're
too young what do you listen to
christian
i listen to more like rap so like will
smith oh
old school rep all right um like
what kind of rap um the baby no
uh well yeah yeah but like like mac
miller two two g's
uh pop smoke uh polo g little tj
but i do like like aerosmith um
yeah who who sings monday monday
manic monday no no monday monday
i don't know it's like an older song
hate that song all right well
i like how he just pushed christian
are you looking for liam no you got to
go to like youtube stuff like liam
gallagher's funny moments
and you just hear him say the funniest
[ __ ] yeah he's just he's got a lot of
opinions
on keith richards and george harrison
beetles and stones they're jealous in c
l and not getting enough
[ __ ] meat pies chris martin looks
like a geography teacher
what's all that with writing messages
about free trade if he wants to write
things down i'll give him a pen and a
pad of
paper a bunch of students i i think
you're winning me over on this team
i don't even know if i met him like i
didn't know you're a singer i just love
your
uh i love your other work i like your
troll job you're doing it
yeah yeah funny moment yeah man it's
interesting yeah they have a cult
following man
i know it's a big following yeah yeah
they're massive like so they came back
is there always rumors of them coming
back no they they
there's never rumors because they they
can't get along you know what i mean
how can they what is it money no
monsters brothers work together i mean
it's just you gotta
i mean that's how it was like they grew
up pretty crazy their their father was
like
pretty abusive all that stuff so they
just dealt with all that and
one was treated differently so there's a
lot there's a lot of
i think for chappelle oasis helped you
out of a tough time too right like
that's why
it's all of it oh he does yeah i got a
testicle
yeah i gotta live forever tattooed on my
own hate yeah yes i wasted tattoos
tattoos come on dude i had no idea he
has a giant
tit tat that says [ __ ] oasis baby
then i got my rancid tattoo right there
rancid yeah it's very funny to ask him
you asked me like so what band are you
into and he's got
the most oasis like like today
he's like i'll show you my shirt
and then you love uh black flag yeah
who's the lead senior rollins
well one of them is jimmy rollins and
that was that's my i got to yeah i got
to perform with him uh
back in 2019 wow at a rock festival
henry rawlings pretty cool
yeah it was he was he was amazing it's
crazy he's sober right never did
any drugs he's always
he drinks carrot juice and [ __ ] he just
randomly starts doing push-ups out of
nowhere yeah just because
you know he's great yeah that that yeah
that was
if i'd say the the one thing that got me
through
my crazy childhood it was probably
rollins that makes sense
with his poetry or spoken yeah spoken
word and all that stuff i've seen him
speak quite a few times and
that's you know he's just he's just a
dude like what i love about him he's a
dude that
he just stays curious you know what i
mean he's always trying to learn yes
always trying to like educate that's why
we gotta do that was it eight what is it
eight pm club what's that in washington
9 30 club yeah because that's all you
and i have done yeah i've done it by
myself
you and i should go do it because it's
like henry rollins that's where
yeah that's a big deal have you done
that club nate really i don't think so i
don't know
no indeed like but i've done the improv
is it uh a regular do they do regular
shows there is it like a headlining kind
of thing
headlining uh it's a big club i feel
like i did hear about that have you
ever done a dc comedy loft uh no
no no i did now i went there and did
last time i forget i was some warner
theater or something i think i i did
arlington an improv and then i think
after providing
how long have you been working in
theaters nate how long have you been a
theater comic
uh it's not been crazy so like last year
i
feel like so was it 2020 take the
panthers so 2019.
so 2018 was uh i don't know whatever
this special came out
uh 2019 that special came out tennessee
kid
so towards the end of that probably and
then i had a year
i guess or 2019 something did it did
about it i finally and i talked to bert
about it all the time if you want to
talk about anyone about like
theaters and ticket prices like no one
knows more about it than bert
like he's obsessed with it so whenever i
talk about like going on tour
i talked to bert about ticket prices and
it's fascinating to me
like in theaters and it is what it is
but like in order to make like real
money like you'd make in a
in a in a club you got to sell that
theater out at least twice
two to two to three times to make real
money because you pay you're only doing
once you're paying for that theater
so you get paid for the staff you gotta
rent that [ __ ] theater out so you're
really getting about
they're taking about six percent of your
pay wow so yeah so really
yeah so if you can do two shows in a
night you're already covering your nut
so that next show you're taking off
you're taking the dough taking it off
that's where you're getting your nut
from
so it's with like in so you can be able
to fill a theater twice twice
to make real money but it's like to me
it's like
and it did each their own if you see a
comic doing like one night in the
theater
it's usually an ego play because like
dude you could make so much money if you
did the club do the clothes but they
they're announcing all these theaters
and it's like oh bubba you're not
like yeah i get it you're gonna make
more money i think that it depends on
the theater but once you get up to
more theaters you make you make you make
more
you make what you make one show versus a
weekend at a club
depending depending on the size of the
theater yeah like if it's a
maybe i guess if it's a thousand seat or
something like that but if you start
getting two thousand three thousand seat
theaters
it's it's a it's e you can get some more
towns
you're covering your night on the rental
yeah the theater yeah and there you go
yeah yeah yeah you're still making uh i
mean you can make a lot but you gotta
think
if you go like you go to stand-up blog
phoenix like a big club like that like
yeah you can make a ton of money with
like or wes
in west palm beach improv and then like
you can make a ton of money
through that because you you sell out
all those shows but you need the entire
weekend it's got to be sold out
that's a lot so that's a lot of shows
and then so the theaters you start
building
into you get to go to a different town
every night and go into the theaters if
you do have a show it is
yeah it's gigantic to get ahead of show
you can make a lot of money there
but then i think the leap i remember
someone always said the leap up to like
making five grand a weekend like you
basically
it's a road up to five grand a weekend
and then after five grand it's like
it goes above that it's a big jump
because then you get past
and if you get past like uh where you're
doing door deal
are you you're first you're doing like
you get uh stuff guaranteed
yeah then you go to yeah you want to get
in percentages that's the
as anybody is like it's almost usually
if you're a good headliner you get like
80
of the door yeah on the theater no
of the club oh the of the club theater's
a different animal yeah theaters are its
own thing but you build a whole tour
like
but theater dude there's nothing better
than like when you see everybody going
into this theater and
you're like you know like they're out
there getting their
popcorn and the yeah and i talked about
it but i think with rogan about it but
like he
like where it's like you feel like
you're like who are they here to see
like you don't feel like it's you
because it's so crazy to be you know
i'll be in some theaters in nashville
where you're like i mean i've watched
seinfeld in this theater then you're
there and you're like
what is happening like it's crazy and
but then you're a show
then you're you start looking at it as
like you're like yeah dude you're
you're in you're the show so you have to
that's when like you gotta you know you
need to do a little bit longer time you
can't
just do 45 minutes like it's you gotta
have this thing yeah you have music when
they sit down like it's kind of
you know it's like music what's the
playlist of the music that's playing
when they sit down and what's the vibe
that you
give off what music fits with that like
yeah consideration for everybody and
you've talked about like bert
tell you the difference between if you
increase the ticket price by three
dollars to fi like
five dollars like the the the fall off
from five dollar increase to ten dollars
i'm
fascinated with so those group behaviors
like my friend said now with restaurants
i've had a couple of friends who have
restaurants they go
what's really weird is because covid had
people
making their homes easier to live in
like they have [ __ ] to do at home
they don't hang out in restaurants as
long they'll eat
and get out they get out somebody drinks
it's actually good because you can turn
over the table that makes sense so you
don't people are not hanging out as long
as it takes
yourself more money but it's like how do
you measure that but what they're doing
is they're going oh i i have stuff to do
at home now
i used to not but because i've been at
home for a year i'm more used to that
i'm going to eat
and i want to get back home so it might
be 20 minutes might be 30 minutes you
don't even notice it
but for whatever reason you don't linger
at the table it's a big deal
and that plays a factor in the economy
that's something economists can never
really take into account because
like you can have a measure [ __ ] like
that yeah it's weird ramifications
there's some current events what do you
got
i just want to use the word the word
ramifications i see yeah you wanted to
throw that in there
as a solid word yeah you used it well
thank you buddy okay what gets you
excited do you ever like go what the
[ __ ]
you seem super sure but his eyes yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah no yeah i could
get you know get
going i could get pumped up i'm very
passionate about something i can get
fired up
are you a drinker i i haven't for like a
couple years
you're sober yeah did you have a problem
uh i just
it was in the way of i could tell that
you know you go on and you're
thursday night you have a great show you
try new stuff then you go out and have a
party after that and then the rest of
the shows you're kind of phoning in and
you're like because you feel like
garbage yeah
like last night i got a call from zanies
i'm at dinner
zanies i go hello and they go hey man
uh we got steve here i love that i'm
putting them on a blast i'm going to
talk about this tomorrow on the [ __ ]
podcast
he go they go hey uh steve um would you
have steve's address i was like
steve burns
tie one on yeah he's he likes to those
are i mean those are
great drunk though yeah very very happy
he's got a good run out there because
you got
theo vaughn is out there now you've got
stuff you're the main guy you got josh
wolfe out there
i let him all know i'm the main guy
i met him at the state line pr guy yeah
like you you're clear with nate
yeah yeah i get brandon he's standing
there with me at the state line
hey don't come down here and thank you
running everything at zany's all right
you think in that one parking spot in
the back
if i might do 15 i might do 30. but i
decide yeah
and i'll let you know how much time i
want you to do yeah i'm the dane cooker
yeah yeah
you're getting intense right now
oh he's fired up you mentioned all the
new comics coming to [ __ ] nashville
man
blowing up everything it's a good thing
competition gets it
in nashville or austin man that's where
all the cameras i'm a big nashville
you know i know i know austin's like
cool like but i mean we always get
compared or
all you know austin's like this new city
that's always blowing up you're like
dude we're
we're so much better nashville
it's i got them going we're uh yeah
we're we're going
to go look at our sky our
vibe though to me no it's it's it's
what's we're like a
mini chicago we're going we're going to
be the real dude all the entertainment's
there
oh yeah there's a ton of people broadway
was packed he's getting fired up hold on
that's great that's six mile radius it's
great dude it's great better than austin
all right what do you got chin here we
go so
adam sandler is going viral again
because he randomly
came to a basketball court and started
playing a pickup game of basketball with
people in long island
please he does that all the time he
balls you know why wear such baggy
clothes
he's self-conscious of his body really
yep that's why he's really who told you
those
a friend oh she's really close to them
but he's playing ball in a polo look at
him go bro
yeah flexing on him what kicks is it
he plays all the time all the time it's
so dope to see
he just randomly came to this basketball
court and was like can i get in
uh-huh talk to me look at him look at
him let's go pass
split
he definitely goes uh i have to be
shirts though
oh we're standing down he's like i'll go
yeah yeah cause i'll just buy this court
yeah and now we're shirts
oh they didn't tell you about the court
man yeah
okay so uh prior to
kurt cobain's death his hair stylist was
on the road with him and cut his hair
she actually had a baggie full of it she
doesn't say why
but she ended up keeping the hair the
hair is now being auctioned off
she knows why and for six strands six to
seven strands somebody bought it for
fourteen thousand dollars
oh someone already bought it yeah
because there is something here's the
thing
spelling entire bank account
your stimulus check all of it i was like
okay yeah the hairstylist set
uh had sold the baggy full of hair
to one individual man and he's selling
strands
now so you guys all i want so he has the
majority of it but he sold
six to seven strands of kurt cobain's
hair for 14 grand did they have to do
dna tests or anything or
i don't know yeah i don't know
you don't want to be like he's like well
how many can i get he's like as many as
you want you're like i don't like that
answer like he's like
makes this dead man he happened
or not yeah what great hair i wish i had
hair like his
go up go up let me see his hair here no
no keep going keep going
no down down no keep going down down
one more time one more time there we go
that's the look
i want i wanted a josh wolfe glasses i
wish i had hair like that
i'm so i get depressed when i see her
like did you ever grow your hair long i
can't it grows off your hair
as a kid i've been talk
get a wig don't give them a wig
this makes me angry my mother says this
to me
in all seriousness she goes she goes
just wear a wig
yes and i'm like i don't know what you
are talking about like
what am i going to do thanks for mark
hello mark
uh he does something with his hair at
night
i'm not going to wear a wig you wear a
wig dude they have really good lace
fronts now daddy's not doing daddy daddy
you got your face
you got your lids done i know dude did
you know he got cosmetic surgery on his
eyes uh i think i heard him because he
has nice she had nuts hanging up
what is he got very oh yeah you won't
have to get the operation
for me hey did you is is the joke about
you having big eyes
on a special yeah it's on uh this one
[ __ ] it's funny
yeah yeah big eyes your eyes will be
fine yeah
your face is getting you have strong
face what
you have strong face dude i'll get a
[ __ ] wig dude and i'll
talk about it on the show i don't give a
[ __ ]
you don't need a wig you use joe's wig
no not right now
you'll be gray which won't be bad a
little salt and pepper in there right
now i think
you're gonna need full pepper yeah
that's salt i have a good hair too man
it's your mom's dead right that's what
they say yeah it's bald though
oh my mine had a ton of hair so like my
hair grows
so quick yeah me too i just can't
believe i'm not just like the opposite
of all this
dude i'll be honest i'm going with it my
hair is gross so fast you'll be here
because i have to get it
i hate it's annoying
i'm thinking about shaving i just i sort
of got i got a guy a guy coming at 1 45
to cut my hair that's real yeah that's
how yeah you do a haircut well no let's
keep it why not where are you going to
be here
it's not for you this barber's not for
you why dude i need a haircut
i let the man get a haircut man you're
[ __ ] selfish and everybody's being
mean to me right now
i have to say nothing about your hair
i'm just trying to help you out i love
it i love cats you've already gone under
the knife love cat
you've already gone under the knife i
had a hair transplant too yeah i've
officially had
two plastic surgeries on my head on my
face but rosie had
one or more rogue rosin has the ving
rhames
scar in the back like well i do too i
just do so i got a hair discovery it
didn't mine didn't really take
you you know who's did though pivins
yeah he had
guys here's fantastic now he had a lot
of them but i think like for me
like i just want to wait until they have
hair
cloning i talked to a guy where it's a
while it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen probably probably ten years
oh that okay hopefully you're still
around
man i had a religious guy say that to me
he goes you're not gonna live for very
long and i go
what are you talking about i mean you
know i go i'm
i have very i guess talking to god i
have good you guys yeah the guy is one
step closer
than we are these genes don't matter you
know talking to the guy yeah
no the guy said you have four days
my source is pretty solid and you're out
you got four years left on this earth go
ahead spin whatever money you want on
your hair
it doesn't matter do you come from
long-lived
uh people uh yeah my yeah my grandmother
uh 82 and you know and they were kind of
like they smoked and drank
they drove but they drank a lot and
smoked a lot okay because you're like
even keeled so i feel like people who
are very even killed like you
your heart rate doesn't go well the
blood pressure
kind of like yeah he's good man like my
grandma she's probably
300 pounds she's a hundred and one wow
she swims every day
oh wow every day really yeah i feel like
you'll live a long time you don't think
you're going
yeah name the biggest grandpa you know
name the biggest korean guy you know and
how old he is
i feel like they're 50 or a thousand
it's gonna go a long
way it's the other way i always say that
you might live forever dude
did you ever hear donald trump's theory
on aging like he never exercises
so many beats yeah he says you have your
body has a battery and if you use up the
battery
it's kind of an interesting theory it's
also the stupidest theory ever
your body is mcdonald's in the white
house right yeah your body has a
there was a triathlete on a staff he
goes you're going to die early and the
guy's like no
he's like your body's a battery and you
have a certain amount of reserves and
once you're depleted can you imagine
this staff knowing
that they're like [ __ ] up yeah yeah
is that you saying he eats real bad
horrible yeah we got a guy who works
hamburgers and like he's
like going the first presents like only
eat like fast food all the time he had a
button
on on his desk this is great he hit a
button and as soon as biden come
came in he got rid of it he had a button
where he just gave him diet cokes all
day
you drink like 12 cokes a day someone
said that was a big reason why they
people liked him so much that like he
ordered mcdonald's yeah he's like us
and like and that was like everybody's
like i ordered mcdonald's yeah but he
looks like
an american yeah but it was a that was a
big thing to be like oh this guy can
relate this guy's
get it he's not an idiot yeah
alrighty so this is a clip from a random
pro wrestling event
where a stunt went wrong i like to start
rock
that's way too much that's too much way
too much way
too much no this is not real oh they
gotta go
oh god this is the box what are they
gonna do
just wait for it there's more is he like
holy [ __ ] there's more just wait for it
ah
take your [ __ ]
speaking of jim cameron
you know what i like the commitment
though because there's 22 people in the
status
for the love each other's dicks we got
to put on a show
like dude you ever seen the undertaker
do this i don't think so just [ __ ]
get on the ground
the the headline is pretty aggressive i
know
i don't know i mean like it's like it's
just that door like i know there's gonna
be like a rooster when you said [ __ ]
yeah you're so aggressive that's a very
like you're like well maybe dude
put that in the description don't know
like yahoo news can pop that up like
the pro wrestler who his cog where he
has where he puts your hand on it and
then he like flips you with it
who's that guy his dick we tried to look
for him before but then we couldn't find
him but then everyone sent us
like a bunch of links that was like his
signature that's a real thing yeah
yeah it takes is it wwe or one of those
it's like a lower promotion i think
i'm 38 you know yeah i can't watch that
stuff
but people love it they have a message
no i was i was a big uh i'm 42. so i was
a big
uh stone cold i watched growing up
hulk hogan and when
me too and then uh and then it was like
stone cold and raw when it was rock and
stone cold yeah and like that was like
that error that was like the greatest
thing i've ever seen
and then we just talked about this with
john i just on our podcast because then
john cena is when i got out
because it was like he wore like short
jeans
like his jeans jeans did yours and
you're like you're like
it makes you feel weird to be like i
would like him to wear some tighter
stuff
like that it looked like when he showed
up like he has to put all his like
wallet out all the stuff he has to put
on yeah he's got his keys
he's unloading them all outside like
baggy like yeah yeah angular like
they're like he drops his leg on you
like did you leave your wallet and he's
like i'm sorry
i forgot i had it in these jeans and you
want to be like dude just wear
it be like everybody like you know you
feel weird yeah just get the other way
wear some underwear dude like don't be
why are you being weird wearing shorts
yeah i don't know that there are two
things i don't care about that
professional wrestling and ufos like
dave what do you think of the ufo
like i i don't i don't know i i don't
know what to say about i don't we need
to wrap your head around it because
they're here
yeah but that's why i talk about in my
act now what are we gonna do
i don't know i've asked i say this in my
act my new act because i talked about it
in the old in the last special
and uh but it's like they're they're
gonna kill us because they're
they're here and we're not there and
that's not good like
like if we were there it'd be better but
the fact that they keep
saying it and everybody's taking it in
stride
dude this is like from a movie dude
they're going the movie's real we got
our own
aliens are here and everybody's like
just kind of just driving around well
you should be in the streets
i don't know what we should be there
nice though you better hope so
i i do hope you better hope yeah
probably not but also maybe those
ufos are just secret military i don't
believe that because we'd have the same
technology no i'm saying maybe it's
american technology and they're just not
telling the pilots
they're not in yeah it's not like
because you're in the military well
that's it
i do i do think it might be a ufo a ufo
it's an alien but
what are we gonna do with it i'm trying
to get this [ __ ] mask off i don't
care about the aliens that's what i mean
let me get the map i know but dude
they're not focused on that
do you know how crazy it is though to
not really be bothered with
aliens like you know why so but there's
nothing we can do
i know i know and it's all it is but
it's just funny that like it's
i i there's nothing we can do but it's
just funny to be like we all just kind
of like yeah
but also about our day dude you're like
yo man this is like
you're watching independence day like
it's like it's here dude you're seeing
mars
yeah yeah it's happening right now
why is the footage still grainy like
well find me one where i wore it can you
show me one
where that's like bigfoot though they
can't like find me one they don't have
it yeah
here let me see it once again it's
always grainy but this is like the
newest thing that came out right now
this is the newest one yeah
oh there it is so yeah why does it look
like that uh we live in 2020 yeah but
but those jacks don't have [ __ ]
4-hd yeah i think they're so far away
from them too like the ufo's
so far away from them that this they're
like looking through a telescope like
is you can't we can't just get up on
them yeah but have you ever seen any
military
like the footage it's never what like
even though
osama footage all right here's what i
have to say we have satellites we're
going to bring the label we have
satellites
from the 80s the satellite technology
could read a label on a golf ball
from the 80s why what the [ __ ] is this
now
i want that i wouldn't be i would be i
was in the 80s it was 89
in 89 they said we have a satellite that
can read the label of golf
so everybody go [ __ ] yourself
until i see can it not be i
i can see better underwater than that
[ __ ] yeah and then watch it let's
watch that
watch i think americans don't care just
because we're dealing so much [ __ ]
yeah we'll watch this so it's like wow
it's getting close see i don't care
tonight off the coast of california
newly leaked video allegedly shows one
of the us navy's stealth nope oh it's at
night too dude no
footage obtained by filmmaker jeremy
corbell who last month released another
video of an upside down pyramid ufo
hovering above a navy destroyer this is
part of it what
i couldn't tell that was an upside down
pyramid wait let me see i know
right now i don't trust that that's it
we're going to be uh the panic it's got
an antarctica video
why would they not because we can't
handle it is it yeah you can't handle
why don't we borrow him to death with
that video
that video was sunny you're like
i know i'm not no energy but liven it up
a little bit like
i was telling you someone entertaining
to talk about it
yeah i was staring at the clock the
entire time yeah yeah
i just wonder if it's a technology
nobody knows about that we're using
like right now there's a secret
government program that's dealing with
practices you know like the the darpa or
the uh the department of energy
they're working on these really cool
ideas like they have material on the
outside of a building
the hotter it gets the colder it gets
inside or the colder it gets outside the
hotter it gets so that so like
i believe no that's you don't have the
clearance
it might be right there
what else you got jen you had the
clearance why are you maybe holy [ __ ]
um remember cat brought up the article
with uh
adam sandler going to an ihop yeah
getting turned down
or not did he you could it was like a 30
minute wait so he didn't wait
so then he didn't know who he was yeah
that too because of the mask
well he went back there and uh i guess
he joked around he commented on that
post saying like oh because they didn't
have like all
free milkshakes all day or something
like that so they actually did a whole
monday milkshake thing where they gave
milkshakes away for
like a bunch of hours 12 to 8 p.m and
then he met up with that girl again
and that's her right there can't play
the music though
there uh that's crazy if you're that
famous
that a you come in and have a little one
that's why the guy can't go anywhere
you have a little inner re interaction
with someone
and then the company gives milkshakes to
millions of people
yeah like it's pretty wild yeah he's
like all right i guess yeah like go back
yeah it's like dude won't you come out
let's just go to ihop real fast he's
like i don't know what it becomes a
thing
what could it be
i like that he's wearing uggs i know
right he's just decked out hurts my soul
chilling farming shorts and uggs
well there's that um this was
interesting
so there was a shrunken head inside a
university of some
university in georgia and it turned out
to be an actual real head it was
supposed to be
like a prop so it was used in this movie
for in the 1970s from john huston
and they did all these different tests
and found out it's actually a really
head it's a real head that one
from the middle for sure is
so yeah mercenary university in macon
and that's the head right there
so it belongs to ecuador is that an
alien
there's a lot of cutting of heads off in
places in the world and it's going to go
back to ecuador
i wish i had those nasal passages
what you gonna do is hit it back to
ecuador and like here you all go and
they're like
we don't want to die i appreciate it man
i don't like
all right with the other hands yeah
no i got to get rid of this dude oh god
and that dead head still has better head
than you brad
has better hair he does still to this
day
right now you would you would switch yes
i would you would switch yes i would
i would in in uh i went to uh indonesia
and the diax
the the sort of original people of those
areas
that some of them had machete like
things where their grandfathers
had the hair in them like in the handle
of the people that they the the other
warriors
whose heads they cut off and then took
their hair and like that's my little
artifact
i remember seeing that when i was like
in my twenties i was like damn these
dudes
i was like all right well there you go
what are you doing out there don't worry
about it
i was studying around i think he told
you you're setting orangutans realizing
that i didn't want to be a naturalist
because it's
too boring it's so boring what else you
got jane
uh this third another mlb player got hit
in the head
oh god oh [ __ ] 94 miles per hour guys
keeping him in the face i don't know
it's like a real problem
this is 94 to the face mm-hmm uh kevin
his nose up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this past two weeks i've had uh i've
pitched
or not pitched but i've batted so i'm
friends with uh some guys that played
baseball vandy's sonny gray
he uh and he uh plays for the cincinnati
reds he's a pitcher and so they were
getting ready for the season i went and
like was kind of watching him warm up
and like
get ready for the season and he was then
he told me he's like staying
standing in the batter's block he's like
just standing there just like and i was
like
no i mean dude this is so hard he didn't
hit me anything but i asked him i was
like how do
you feel amazing right now dude like
yeah like do you feel
real good like i don't need you to be
like you're kind of like i get some
covet shake off yeah i guess you get one
to the head
but it's so fast when you're standing
to be safe they come it comes in so
quick
it's terrifying that guy right there
yeah yeah he's great dude he's from uh
smyrna to the sea local dude straight up
real
local guy like you know he's the best
kevin bay wanted me to do that stan
in the batter's box with his one of
these guys
he had some guy who's throws over he's
not going to hit you i go i i i'm just
not into it
wow he pitches really fast khan are you
in the [ __ ] yeah
you want to be like can i stand outside
the batter's box yeah i'd rather just
watch
batting pranks i'll stand behind the
thing yeah i don't need to see it i'm
squeamish about explosives and really
fast pitches
that's why i quit baseball like when i
was like when you go from 12
to 13 13 year old league baseball like
the kids can't
it's the first time you go to a farther
mound and the kids can't you're not
strong enough to really throw it that
quick so that was like my dream spot
dude
like if you got hit by a pitch it just
didn't hurt because they couldn't get it
there but then 14 like
they grow and then they start then they
start moving and i was like i'm out dude
oh 14 is where they really start kicking
ass that's when they start throwing yeah
get bigger
13 was like a mate 12 was tough because
they're close
and they could throw and they're so
close to you and at 13 they go back and
no one really knows how to time that out
right
so it's just kind of a softer throw and
at 14
then it gets real yeah and they're wild
because it's kids like
just [ __ ] throwing the crazy crazy
just like
all right this is not really compelling
video but you know those little dust
devils you see
yeah just real small ones around yeah so
this one apparently picked up a 70 pound
dog and threw it in the air what yeah
wood in the air
you guys look at the video tell me it's
already this is actually take a look at
this video from the hinton area of
rockingham county on thursday
this right here that's the dust devil
now it didn't last
very long because it's about to get them
here on occasion but the conditions have
to be
just right now with the weather being
very dry lately
that is a big factor this is video of
one from weir's cave on tuesday
the dust devil is very hard to see but
it lifted this dog in the air you can
see the little bit of dust there too
right the area behind the flag
but this one pound dog
the dog duke is a lab and thankfully he
is okay
now dukes but then yeah that would be
terrifying but then it also kind of
looks like the dog's just
jumping too you know dog had a good time
for that american flag
it's a blue lodge like you know the
neighborhood
falcon hunting out there you know what
it is you get a little further out in
tennessee and you see some [ __ ] you're
like oh okay well there's a confederate
flag
yeah that's southern pride [ __ ] you're
like i got it yeah
we look we keep you on your toes don't
wander too far from the city
that's okay is that itching that's it
all right
well nate we're on the road next man uh
i'm improv
soon yeah miami improv is this weekend
that's sold out and then uh
naples go to naples because that one is
uh
naples and then my entire tour just got
uh
uh we will add a bunch more cities
because you get asked that a lot but the
it went on sale today pre-sale pre-sale
uh so uh that's all going up on sale
starting off in
yeah reno vegas and then the back to the
theaters
you'll love off the hook man comics hit
on it but it was a great club
it was fun yeah it was great i liked it
yeah yeah it's great
and i love i love captain brian tampa
florida i'll see you this weekend
may 21 and 22 tomorrow night
uh wednesday night zany's me steve byrne
doing it big and hungry
nate bargati is not going to be there
but he has been there so if you want to
see a stage he performs on usually
you give him a shot and then toledo all
these people show up based off that
yeah toledo ohio funny bone everybody
may 28 to the 30th san antonio texas
june 3rd the 5th albany albany i got to
take that that's right
that's that's june 18 19 philadelphia
helium train about
56 27. it'll bomb me train the ball it's
going to hurt my feelings chappelle and
i
are in houston this weekend thursday
friday saturday houston
improv let's ride houston may 20 through
22nd then oklahoma city
brickstown comedy club june 10th through
the 12th the only date on the right now
is september 30th through october
2nd mama i'm coming home denver colorado
comedy works
downtown tickets at f-a-t-k-z.com
for brian chappelle and myself and then
appleton wisconsin skyline
skyline comedy club june 4th and 5th uh
chappelle ac.com for tickets
uh i'm excited for appleton i don't know
i just did it you just did it
yeah it's great great that's a big
famous club that a lot of comics
recorded albums out of appleton
uh the crowds are really good there it's
not a it's not a huge club and it's uh
just been there for a while and like it
they see it really well
uh yeah but it's like they have you can
stay uh
there's a downtown appleton's kind of
downtown okay and then uh but it's
it's a really good club the audiences
are really great and uh yeah a lot of
comics have recorded albums there oh
so yeah that's that's the sign of a good
club when because everybody knows like i
can trust
the crowd trust that crowd oh okay then
i'm super excited nate we love you man
yeah i'm a big fan thank you guys for
having me yeah love you guys